[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du skycho le magazine qui
raconte toutes les aventures économiques
du territoire de Saint-Quentin en
iveline pour cette nouvelle édition nous
allons plonger dans le monde de
l'industrie de l'innovation et de la
technologie française parce que du 27
novembre au 3 décembre se déroulait la
Semaine de l'industrie pour l'occasion
des entreprises industrielles du
territoire de sa-quanttin en iveline
ouvraient leurs portes le but susciter
des vocations et renforcer
l'attractivité de leur métier nous avons
justement participé à l'une de ces
visites nous y reviendrons un petit peu
plus tard dans cette émission mais tout
de suite voici le sommaire du 27
novembre au 3 décembre 2023 entreprisees
industrielle et école ouvrait leurs PES
pour la Semaine de l'Industrie
l'objectif démystifier les métiers de
l'ingénieur surtout chez les jeunes
femmes point de rencontre et d'échange
vecteur de mutualisation pôle
d'expertise ou encore incubateur de
projets innovants depuis 10 ans le club
climat énergie de 50 ans en Eveline
s'engage pour promouvoir les questions
relatives au climat et à l'énergie
quelles ont été leur action depuis leur
création décryptage dans cette émission
mais tout de suite je vous emmène chez
Airbus et au technocentreena pour la
Semaine de
[Musique]
l'Industrie susciter des vocations et
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers de
l'industrie surtout auprès des femmes la
Semaine de l'industrie se tenait du 27
novembre au 3 décembre à cette occasion
toute la semaine entre industrielles et
éc ouvraent leurs pte pour plonger dans
le monde de l'industrie de l'innovation
et de la technologie française et pour
cette 12e édition c'est l'entreprise
Airbus qui lance les hostilités le site
accueillit une centaine de jeunes pour
la journée aujourd'hui chez Airbus c'est
justement montré à la fois nos activités
industrielles asses jeunes qui vont
découvrir ça souvent pour la première
fois essayer de susciter des vocation et
puis
également leur montrer que l'industrie
c'est pas uniquement Airbus c'est aussi
aussi des start-ups ces jeunes vont
découvrir que Ben dans les start-ups il
y a aussi des métiers intéressants et
que c'est peut-être là qu'ils
démarreront leur carrière ou qu'ils
créeront eux-mêmes leur propres start-up
dans quelques années d'ailleurs c'est le
thème cette année c'est prépare ton
avenir pour justement préparer l'avenir
l'agglomération de saint-quentinveline a
voulu mettre l'accent sur la
féminisation du secteur souvent associé
aux hommes pour démystifier ses métiers
de l'ingénieur et sensibiliser les
jeunes filles l'association ellebouge
était présente chez Airbus son objectif
montrer aux jeunes filles que les
métiers de l'ingénierie et du technique
sont accessibles même s'il y a beaucoup
d'hommes justement on aimerait leur
montrer que c'est un métier qui est
accessible et que si ça leur plaît il
faut foncer j'avais à cœur en fait
depuis que je suis étudiante comme j'ai
fait ce constat là queon était vraiment
pas nombreuse de rejoindre une
association ça me permet de d'aller des
fois dans des collèges dans des lycées
pour faire des présentations de faire un
témoignage aujourd'hui directement à
Airbus pour la Semaine de l'Industrie et
et voilà j'espère que ces actions là ont
un impact et que dans le futur on verra
un changement pour les visiteuses du
jour c'est peut-être l'occasion de
déceller des vocations c'est vrai que on
c'est eu un peu une chance quand même de
visiter C Airbus parce que c'est quand
même une grosse industrie et ça permet
de voir aussi pas mal de métiers
différents et pour l'orientation c'est
plutôt bien à la base c'était pas trop
mon idée d'orientation mais j'ai quand
même trouvé ça intéressant de découvrir
une autre voie possible pour cette
semaine consacrée à l'industrie Renault
avait aussi organisé des visites avec
des établissements scolaires ce mardi 28
novembre c'était au tour des étudiants
de l'école d'ingénieurs ei it d'être
accueilli au Technocentre au programme
visite du site et sensibilisation à
l'intelligence artificielle alors je
veux montrer aux jeunes que Renault ben
on n'est pas que des plieurs de tô on
n'est pas que des gens qui qui faisont
des révisions et on est aussi des gens
qui faisont de la haute technologie et
qui faisont de l'IA et on espère bien
attirer les jeunes les plus dynamiques
et les plus malins pour faire de
l'intelligence artificielle avec nous
outre l'intervention sur l'intelligence
artificielle les étudiants ont pu
visiter le site et découvrir de nouveaux
métiers une journée qui leur donnera
peut-être des idées de projets futurs et
c'est intéressant on découvre d'autres
domaines c'est c'est pertinant c'est un
endroit très grand et que franchement
que j'aimerais peut-être un jour revenir
travailler ici depuis 2011 la Semaine de
l'Industrie a pour objectif de créer des
passerelles entre le monde économique et
la sphère académique un enjeu majeur
pour l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Éveline laabéisé territoire
d'industrie allez on continue ce numéro
avec le club clima énergie qui fête ces
10 ans cette année pour l'occasion nous
sommes partis à la rencontre de Bertrand
cocard et Xavier de la Porte pour mieux
comprendre les actions qu'il mène depuis
ces 10 années allez
[Musique]
suivez-moi le club k energy c'est un
recroupement de compétences d'experts de
différentes sociétés qui ontvie de
devrait sur le territoire pour faciliter
la transition énergétique et surtout
inventer et mettre en place des des
bacassabl des expérimentations autour de
[Musique]
l'énergie au départ on a créé le club il
y a 10 ans effectivement pour travailler
sur la mutualisation des réflexions de
différentes entreprises par rapport aux
problématiques de la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre on a mené différentes
actions d'expérimentation et aussi de de
mise en place on a parlé de skisher qui
est le covoiturage d'une voiture une
idée de deux trois entreprises qui sont
mises ensemble pour pouvoir
effectivement effectuer des des trajets
de cours ou moyenne distance avec le
covoiturage des solutions économiques
intéressantes et qui préservve la
[Musique]
planète nous n'imaginions pas lorsque
nous avons créé le club climaénergie
donc en 2013 que nous aurions à vivre
une crise énergétique comme celle que
nous avons connu en
2022223 celle-ci a montré encore plus
d'actualité par par rapport à nos
réflexions nos acteurs nos partenaires
nous ont dit mais comment on fait
l'évolution a été de travailler sur les
sujets de l'énergie puisque très
rapidement s'est posé la question par
rapport à nos partenaires de comment
réduire le coût de l'énergie et comment
réduire être plus efficient dans la
manière de consommer son énergie
c'est-à-dire de mettre en place des
procédures des processus qui permettra
de consommer moins les prochains défis
du club clima energy c'est d'essayer de
d'expérimenter des nouvels formats de je
dirais d'énergie donc on passe notamment
à l'autoconsommation c'est quelque chose
qu'on essaie de mettre en place dans les
différentes communes en liant toujours
l'aspect privé puisque en terme de je
dirais établissement public on est assez
armé pour mettre en place des
expérimentations pour répondre à leurs
[Musique]
demandes on termine avec l'agenda ce
mois-ci ne manquez pas l'événement
l'avenir àortter de main si vous êtes à
la recherche d'un emploi d'un stage ou
d'une alternance rendez-vous le 14
décembre prochain au ski cube car
Saint-Quentin en Eveline et
l'association NQ s'associe et propose de
13h à 17h30 des ateliers pour booster la
recherche d'emploi ou d'alternance grâce
à un format innovant c'est la fin de ce
numéro merci de l'avoir suivi à bientôt
sur
[Musique]
tv78